في المقابل شدد الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد
على ضروره توفير احتياجات المواطنين مشيرا
الى ان التحدي الاقتصاديه والاجتماعي يعد
من اهم تحديات التي يواجهها التونسي
مع رئيسه الحكومه ووزيري العدل والداخليه
نفسي على الازمات وفقدان بعض المواد
الاساسيه وغلاء الاسعار والمحاولات التي
باتت معلومه للجميع لا يمكن ان تستمر حسب
التعبير
البلاد لشهر اضافي والى غايه 30 من يناير
المقبل وفق مرسوم رئاسي صدر في الجديده
الرسميه
الذي استهدف حافله لان الرئاسي وسط
العاصمه في نوفمبر من عام 2015
الينا من تونس مراسله الجزيره مساء
الفطناسي ميساء اهلا بك اذا ينتهي هذا
العام والوضع لا يزال مشتعل في تونس تمديد
حاله الطوارئ من جهه واحتجاجات للمعارضه
من جهه الثانيه ما التفاصيل
ننتظر السنه القادمه السنه الجديده التي
لا تفصلنا عنها الا ساعات قليله ويبدو ان
ازمات هذه السنه سترحل الى العامه القادم
ونحن مقبلنا على مواعيد كثيره خلال الشهر
الاول من العامه
خلال هذه السنه ايضا ستتواصل الازمه
السياسيه بنفس الحده وبنفس الانقسامات
التي شهدتها خلال العام الماضي والذي قبل
السنه القادمه والعام والشهر القادم شهر
يناير يبدو سي انه سيكون مليء بالاحداث
هذه الاحداث التي ستبدا منذ الخامس من
الشهر الجديد حيث سينفذ المحامون يوم غضب
ايضا في شهر يناير
تتخلله او سيتخلله قال كان قد اعلنت عنه
جبهه الخلاصه الوطني تحرك مهم همم يوم
الرابع عشر من يناير حيث اعلنت الجبهه
بانه خلال هذا التحرك وخلال هذا اليوم
سيتم الاعلان عن تقارب جديد بين صفوف
المعارضه ايضا سنكون امام همم اضراب عام
في قطاع النقل برا وبحرا وجوا وايضا خلال
شهر يناير
سيعقد الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل اجتماع
لهيئته الاداريه هذه الهيئه التي تعتبر
السلطه الاعلى داخل الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل والتي ستقر ربما سلسله من التحركات
التي اعلن عنها الاتحاد وان كان بشكل ضمني
ولكن ستتوضح بعد نهايه هذا الاجتماع ايضا
خلال شهر يناير سنشهد الدور الثاني من
الانتخابات التشريعيه اذا هو عام سيكون
مليء بالاحداث السياسيه في تونس وعم ربما
ستتواصل فيه الازمه السياسيه بنفس
الانقسامات ونفس الحده الانف بالامس
الرئيس التونسي ومن خلال الرائد الرسمي
كان قد اعلن عن تمديد حاله الطوارئ ربما
هذا ليس امرا جديدا باعتبار ان حاله
الطوارئ تمدد بصفه دوريه ومتواصله ومستمره
منذ سنه
2015 ولكن اليوم هناك انتقادات لهذا
الاعلان ولي التمديد الجديد لحاله الطوارئ
باعتبار مخاوف من ان يتم همم
اعتماد الاجراءات المصاحبه والظرفيه
الامنيه المصاحبه لهذه لحاله الطوارئ هذه
من اجل القمع الاحتجاجات الاجتماعيه
والسياسيه وغيرها وقد عبرت بعض الاطراف
المعارضه عن هذه المخاوف الامينه العامه
السابق لحزب التيار الديمقراطيه غازي
الشواشي الذي قال ان التمديد الغايه منه
هو هو قام معه
في التحركات الاجتماعيه والتضيق عليها اذا
هذه هي الاحداث التي تقبل عليها السنه
الجديده في تونس كل المؤشرات تؤكد بان
السنه القادمه لن تكون التحركات وحاله
الحركه السياسيه فيها اقل حده من السنه
التي انتهت
اتمنى لك عام سعيد
معنا من تونس